and jorge lopez trying to win for the
third time kind of a big lead in kansas
city couldn't get out of the fifth
inning which has really kind of been the
one of the problems all year long a 3-1
to start the game and escobar breaks his
bat on a ground ball to michael franco
and that broken bat messed with franco
but the throw is still
just in time to get escobar
and bell attacks a fastball on the first
pitch and a ground out to franco the
lone infielder to the left of the ship
five to six fielders choice will put a
scoreless first to bid
usually i introduce a pitcher i tell you
what he did last time out tonight is all
about the first inning for patrick
corbin because the first inning has been
rough on him all season long by the way
he's two for three against corbin
and
not three for four
juan soto has played a fantastic right
field this year
sliding catch two down getting ready for
the baseball not a problem
in the air
al cetus has the
angle
over patrick corbin in the bottom of the
first it's one
two trace
good at bet by ryan zimmerman
nats have drawn a couple of walks
already
ball pulled hard for a base hit
uria stu is left zimmerman stops at
second
and that's in business with flyout pop
out
now a strikeout of stevenson
got him on the breaking ball for lopez's
first k
2-2 pitch again
corbin trying to strike him out low in
the zone and joe west takes his sweet
time in calling him out
first base dugout not happy at all about
that including brandon hyde
you're not supposed to know what guys
are hitting it for the umpires you're
supposed to call a striker strong
severino
hard to left and para right there
corbin six up six down a great start to
his friday night
payoff pitch turner chases after lopez
sends a breaking ball in full count and
a strikeout two down for lopez 51
pitches
do you follow baseball do you follow one
i do
i do and i know he's got some some mean
juice
well regrettably once soda didn't have
one of his patented knife pitching bats
so we have to let you go because connor
norby's coming in next minute
great to meet you colton we can't wait
to see you down the line this year 2-2
to mckenna 24 year old from grants pass
oregon
that's a nasty slider down and in and
patrick corbin will ring him up for a
second strikeout
and a breaking ball came back around
harrison from near the bag
give josh a glove and send him anywhere
out there he'll do a good job over his
last 28 games josh is it six homers but
driving in 21
and you can see
you
later home runs will come indeed
number 15 rbi number 46
the nets
in baltimore
on top
a towering blast
off a sinking fastball that didn't sink
there he is a breaking ball spoke of
three paralyzed
there's a hand into the corner from
cedric mullins up against the wall he's
thinking two sodos throw not in time
and another double for cedric mullins
only
one man in the american league has more
doubles than his 27. now the orioles
opportunity to see if they can counter
after bell's long home run in the top
half of the inning with austin hayes
who's been swinging the bat well coming
up now that one is last and that's off
the glove of harrison so fair ball
here comes mullins around third to tie
the game the ball got out of play
austin hayes
ties it with an rbi double it was picked
up by the ball boy who thought it was a
foul ball apparently
saw an automatic double for hayes to tie
the score after the double from mullins
corbin dropping the slider into the dirt
and a good block by pereira patrick
third strikeout
so hayes at third ramon urias
is
361 with runners on base
in the right field rius another hit with
a runner on base another hit with a
runner in scoring position a two-run
fourth inning for the orioles who are in
front for the first time tonight
[Applause]
there's a line drive base hit for andrew
stevenson who's going to think two out
of the box
and a double for stevenson
well struck it out on a breaking ball
come right back on a fast ball inside
middle and now trey turner
and now a ball right off the glove of
severino and he's not gonna have a play
at third
lopez even though he has the lead will
not be allowed to go five innings to
qualify for a possible win
fry soto
sounds hot next
[Applause]
and a ground ball to first base and
brandon hides a genius one pitch one out
orioles lead it midway through the fifth
bottom five for the o's
patrick corbin
on three pitches strikes him out
pereira to bell
fourth k of the night for patrick and
now it'll send off pat valencia
valenca out to left center pat valencia
has left the building
his second straight game with a home run
and it's three to one orioles
and he did it on a pitch that usually is
patrick corbin's best pitch
next offering swing and a miss strike
three slider that was buried down and in
it was a beauty from paul fry
slider oh no chance at that one a slider
that darted down and inside
and zimmerman
quickly snapped his wrist forward
and took an awkward half swing full
count
here it is
slider swing and a miss he's struck out
the side
paul frye gets belle
zimmerman harrison and how does he do it
each time off of the slider which was
nasty in that sixth inning
this ball blasted out to right center
trey it's off the wall
trey's gonna take two and
stop right there
uh lead off double for trey mancini in
the sixth
the 2-0
on the ground turner backhand up to the
plate high boom not caught and the
orioles get the run in
and trey's all right two
bang bang play turner really makes a
nice
catch just to catch it but because he
has to backhand it
very difficult to turn and throw a
perfect
throw
wander suero 34th ball game
throw gets away from belle
marias will take second he might keep
going tony mancellino's saying come on
down to third and ramone will
one two
that's in the year that will get the run
in
soto is underneath it in right field but
this will be a sacrifice fly for pedro
severino
and a second orioles run in the sixth
inning
well all these runs are huge
[Applause]
and another good a b
alright two for three tonight
and over a nine game span
he's now 11 for his last 30.
and another good at bat for andrew
stevenson
setting the table here
real fast arm is in the game now for
baltimore
and a first pitch swing from trey turner
didn't get the launch angle right on
this one a punt into left field a long
time in the air for ryan mckenna to put
it away
one pitch two stranded top seven
one out and nobody on for pat valleca a
big blast in the fifth
felaka bidding for another one out to
left center field deep and
gone
back to back at bats
pat the major bat
he thinks he's dj stewart
second career multi-home run game in the
major leagues for pat valencia herrera
pop out ground out strikeout
tate trying to finish it off and a
ground ball right back to him the oriole
bullpen tonight almost perfect
in a series opening win over the nats